of that but let's begin with alex hogan
she is live at the border in mission
texas hi alex
hi dana good morning bill just over this
levy there is a processing site where
many of these migrants who surrender to
border patrol
are processed and we've seen some of
them already here this morning
all of them sharing harrowing stories of
what they've experienced in this journey
just like that little boy again let's
take a listen
to
so this child just walks up to border
agents sobbing again he was traveling in
a group without his family
he explains they left him behind while
heading to the border and crying
he asked the agents where else would he
go if he doesn't go with them
this is a sad new milestone that we're
seeing 19 thousand children are in u.s
custody
each of them just like that little boy
made it all the way to the border
one boy last week he was traveling with
his father
the two swam across the rio grande river
but the father drowned helping his son
get across and that is just
another one of the tragic stories of
these children
arriving here in the u.s unaccompanied
more delegations are announcing their
trips here to the border to see this
humanitarian challenge for themselves an
envoy to the biden administration is set
to return from his trip to the northern
triangle
tomorrow here's a live look at the
border wall in mission texas now many
environmental activists say
they are glad this never should have
been built
while law enforcement here say that the
halted progress
really creates problems of its own
that means now you're controlling or at
least trying to control
and enforce areas that have once been
secure and now are wide open
and then you couple that with the
unaccompanied children family units
and you can't forget that every day
organizations are still encountering
criminal illness
now this is an example of one of those
sections of the wall that is not
finished now
a lot of divided opinions on what to do
but many people
around this area just want questions
about will it get finished will it
remain like this
questions they're hoping they will get
from the government bill dana
thank you alex want to bring in former
acting eyes director tom
holman also a fox news contributor tom
good morning to you i want to show you
the number that dan and i are referring
to a moment ago
projected total unaccompanied minors
crossing the border in this year
184 thousand time you saw the video
what do you think when you see that
well look thank god the little boy's
health uh safe with the bore patrol look
you know that's why i fight so hard bill
and people always ask me why do you get
so emotional on tv and why do you yell
at congress and i testify
they haven't seen what i've seen in my
35 years i've held many dying children
i found many dead children i've i've
talked to women who are raped over 20
times
a third of every woman that comes across
that is
puts themselves with the criminal
cartels a third of them make that trip
get sexually assaulted i've done
investigations where when
when a migrant couldn't pay a smuggling
fee he was tortured he actually called
his family up
tortured him while his family's on the
phone to make him pay the smuggling fee
and they killed him if they didn't so
look illegal immigration not a
victimless crime
you know females get raped i talked to
nine-year-old who was raped
i did a lot of investigation i put a lot
of alien smugglers and human traffickers
in prison my own regret i couldn't put
them all in prison
these cartels are ruthless but the
promises this bite administration the
promises they have made
about you can't be you can enter country
illegally you won't be detained you
won't be deported
uh we're going to give you amnesty and
and free healthcare you you put yourself
in a position
where you can put the most vulnerable
people put themselves in harm's way to
get here because they think they're
going to be released these
policies of by administration are not
inhumane they're not humane as they said
it was
the only humanity i see on the border is
what this video these morbidity agents
saving lives over 4 000 lives saved last
year
and i had this you can hate president
trump or you can like him i don't
care but you can't argue when illegal
immigration was down 70 80 percent under
his administration
how many women didn't get raped how many
children didn't die
how many billions of dollars do the
cartels not make every day
so i think that this administration the
big administration needs to get back to
some of these policies because these
policies
that trump administration had saved
lives tom there's another
aspect of all of this in addition to the
children and the victims of illegal
immigration and
and what the cartels are doing to them
and that is the possibility that um
when they say a hundred thousand
getaways in a possible year could
include
terrorists um two from yemen have been
caught already
don't know how many have not been caught
and kevin mccarthy the minority leader
for the house
he said this last night on hannity
the border agents they told me that they
had caught people on the terrorist watch
list
when i brought that up at the press
conference my democratic colleagues
weren't shocked by it you know what they
did they called me a liar
until we brought forth the answers and
it should not come as a surprise that
the democrats
are troubled by this they are trying to
distract from this disaster
because they created it when there is
chaos in a situation terrorists like to
take advantage of it they also like to
take advantage during a transition from
one administration to the next
is that what's happening here absolutely
great question that's what
that's what makes this humanitarian
crisis a national security crisis
look the board patrols already said 40
of their manpower
is no longer on the line so if you're
somebody in the world wants to come here
and
do us harm and blow something up it's
hard it's almost impossible to get a
plane ticket anymore because all the
database checks
are done with people trying to get a
plane ticket from the united states it's
almost impossible to get a visa anymore
because all the database checks they do
dod databases
and they look for any derogatory
information in the visa security program
protects
that uh protects the issuance of a visa
to somebody who has derogatory
information maybe
you know related or known a suspected
terrorist so if you
if you really want to come to the
country what's the best way to come here
you're going to come the same way 20
million others did to the southwest
border
when 40 40 percent of the border was
normally online the border's vulnerable
so like you said uh
danny said he said it correctly how many
got through that we didn't catch
that's what scares me because there's
over a thousand got aways every day
morbid says over a thousand godawes
based on central traffic
they can't respond to or drone traffic
or camera traffic over a thousand got
aways
so if you want to come this country do
us harm now you know
the border is vulnerable right now
because of the situation created by the
byte administration
thanks tom for your input today tom
homan a lot more to cover here
if you're on the no fly list you know it
right if you're a terrorist because you
probably
try to get on a plane already and and
yet you
as we have seen you can walk across the
border if you can get there
thank you tom one final note here on
this stain there's talk now that they
could plug the holes
quote unquote and some of the border
wall that was unfinished uh
seems like a pretty good idea you see
some of that video from the aerial
pictures there
those gaps are they're vulnerable right
now if i feel like if the biden
administration is thinking about
reversing course on a bad decision
we should help them do it